a show of force by Nigeria's Security
Forces
this is a psychological move to preempt
any violence following elections
across many of those States tension is
high ahead of results being announced
especially in those states that have
been keenly contested
few cases that will come across during
the confidence building Patrol which all
the agencies were a part of and I led
has given the desired competence of the
people that threat will not be used to
intimidate in a border
the streets of Kano in Northern
Nigeria's commercial hub are largely
deserted
business people anxious about what could
happen when results are announced have
locked up
determined to protect their ballots
voters and party supporters are waiting
at result Coalition centers Nationwide
as a Battleground State candle has
always been prone to post-elect violence
Security Forces say they are ready but
analysts warned against underestimating
the potential scale of violence after
the results were announced especially
after the violence that killed several
people in the last presidential election
security is high at the vote counting
centers and what happens in these Halls
will have significant political and
security implications for Africa's
biggest democracy we are referees and we
remain so and whoever citizens chose if
the person those people you see in the
Coalition Center will declare so I'm
absolutely confident about the
transparency of the process
in areas in Lagos who are violence and
voter intimidation have been reported
voting has been held again
vote buying by politicians has also been
recorded around the country
for now it's not clear how much the
violence and irregularities will affect
the credibility of the election results
that everyone's is waiting for Ahmed
Idris Al Jazeera kanu Nigeria